hello there reject nation i'm greg i'm
john
we are gonna watch the finale for the
falcon and the winter soldier today
thank you to all who have been joining
us throughout the weeks for this
subscribe click the notification bell
you know we'll cover loki but check out
some other stuff in the meantime i gotta
give a little bit of a disclaimer if i
seem
a little bit out of it it's not just
because it's midnight it's because i've
been up
since about 6 30 in the morning i got my
second vaccine shot around 10
30 in the morning it's been a lot of
filming editing and collabing today
and uh now it's midnight a lot of people
were telling me you'll feel symptoms
tonight but oh
tomorrow that's what's gonna be really
bad i'm like i can't wait to film the
falcon in the winter soldier finale on
saturday then i'm gonna go until sunday
so it'll be so late the best time to do
it is
tonight thank you for understanding i'm
still excited to check this out feeling
all right
right now
hit that like button thank you to erica
very chronic for editing the reaction
highlights for us and if you want to
watch the full-length stream along
with us you can come on over to
patreon.com
the real rejects we got falcon in the
winter soldier watchalongs where you
sync up with the time code as long as a
bunch of other shows you can see them
look at the images yes we did it we're
here
also have reaction highlights as well
for many of them we totally forgot to
mention this is
part one of our reaction there'll be a
card
end screen pin comment link in the
description box for part two
of our reaction the finale of falcon and
winter soldier
let's get into action people
yeah yeah where's his new suit
get to what i've already seen in the
action figure
[Laughter]
they're not going to stop not unless we
make them
it's time
this looks like that nighttime finale in
uh terminator 2.
oh yeah there is a no-fly
just look excuse me sir are you supposed
to be here
it's me sure
who are you sharon
come on give us a close-up give us a
close-up
[Applause]
[Music]
like under cowl or something i'm sorry
wait who are you captain america he's
captain america
no one's moving i thought captain
america was on the moon
we gotta keep everybody's
i love the cinematography in this
episode yeah and the colors
just the lighting and everything red
signifying the danger i've done this
before a kid
i know how it ends i'm fighting for
something bigger than myself have you
ever been able to say the same
you don't think i ever fought for
something bigger than myself he was an
end game
yeah that's true he fought for planet
earth
for the world man in that whole universe
almost a han zimmer s score yeah i was
gonna say there's definitely some
some dark knight trilogy in here too
i just want like one still shot at the
suit just like one pose
oh my prince
[Music]
what she take or what she plant
oh come on the chair oh
i love that oh damn this is awesome
fly sam
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's cool
see if anyone in there has flight
training right away back
red wing worst case scenario we kill the
hostages
we're supposed to use them to negotiate
to stop that vote
guys she just said it's worst case yeah
it might not even get to that maybe
possibly one world
one doubt one people one people
one people clearly you're all
full of doubt you might as well say
something
oh
that's
[Music]
good stuff cool we need a diversion
give him someone to rescue what do you
mean light it up
huh i love this yeah give him someone a
rescue
completely manipulative
he's a good intention
are you people who needed rescuing
get moving
[Music]
let's go oh my dude i didn't mean to
kill your friend
i don't want to hurt people that don't
matter
wow you don't think lamar's life oh
you're a terrible communicator
oh buddy he's learning
i feel so sorry for the guy sometimes
he's really tried his best he's doing
everything
it's on the inside yeah thank you
for saving us hey
hey someone actually said thanks
[Music]
oh
wow that's pretty cool
cool hand look over here is it a parking
fee
a superhero landing yeah oh
superhero block
[Music]
put in your earbuds a little birdie told
me you know how to fly a helicopter
what we're gonna do requires perfect
timing we're gonna count down from five
when we get to one you're gonna grab the
control
okay you've got this come on
that was a that was a maneuver
i love how you're seeing all the new
ways he can use the shield
yeah yeah
now we're seeing the ways john walker
can use his yes
oh oh my dude
he just immediately goes for the food
this is my move
oh
oh
i love how sometimes like there's just
this subtle use of their super strength
that you don't even really notice it
yeah you're like oh yeah that's like
extremely heavy yeah
so i was thinking with that big car like
these items here yeah yeah
the parking mutant and the beam
well that's great when it ground it too
oh
i'm just gonna catch you
oh is he is he gonna do the right thank
god
walker
what would kept oh damn
[Music]
walker you're all captain america now oh
my dude oh come on
give the guy a break he was
what
oh
oh sam oh what a beautiful shot like an
angel saving the day
yeah i love that ah so beautiful
oh look you there
and bucky even helped up water yeah i
love all this blue lighting too
[Applause]
that's black captain america right there
no just captain america
whoa my man with the catch
nice pinball sam you're handling
everything
[Music]
oh no this guy man
all right come on sharon who are you
that's the end of part one of our
reaction to falcon and winter soldier
people link to part
two above us end screen
pink comment you know what to do go
there there's also a very lengthy review
yeah yeah
[Music]